на mail їх а без добра на жаль вас вирощу
good є на руїни слугу пляшку в
лисичанському
і залишки нашого старого база вежі
нашого старого будинку тепер завдяки
перлза в декрет добрим людям нам до
чи допомогли буду вати, але виїдемо
новий будинок новий but enough коштувати
поради ланки в здоровому які розбомбив
ще 2014 року види разу на початку провини
на донбасі
по 90 столом біля жили вам заводити і
міжнародні фінанси виду допоможемо з 1
з 30 пляшки в які плану етикет буду
вати у нас дуже теку просто так швидкою
сліди провини і у сунуть інше в даєте does a
hill і шопа або ну ти в сад alvis war
шукаю з моря
снаряд я прийшла з роботи і відчинила двері
і even go ось і бруду і він був менше 2
метра та заглушки ціни шоу динзе снаряді
вікі означав їм ольги реальний символ
смертоносні війни проти мирного
населення на сході України to die
проросійські бойовики зайняли салон а
український весь до наступав і
біт вчимося за радіо веду з перебуває
на ставок і будинку бойовики витіснила
2000 у 2014 та ротем алип досвід разом до
фіналу води всі території pid контроль
не проросійським сепаратистам
знаходиться всього за кілок кілометрів
на піф девід місця лисичанська а заходьте
на пару 2 і не б'ються на гвинтику думу
у лінощі обстріли в сочі відривають там
уаля сварки щук даси бійця шукала ті ж
насторожі, і ми вже на сторожі не в нас
напишемо вмістити всі бум мер хочеться
рахунок все вже заз лежала a cool і тут
за по ну і телицю в цій morts поки
поки на веденому той снаряд біля саду алі
зграї щук при б радий і ніхто не поспішаючи